[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá boa tarde a todos e cada um nós com
muito poucos recursos podem fazer algo
diferente pela sua rua
coisas tão simples como organizar um
concerto em sinal de uma técnica que só
nós é que sabemos ou até quem salva
espalhadas pela cidade
no outro ia falar com uma colega minha
sobre isto disse não conseguia perceber
como é que numa grande cidade
não sei quase ninguém fazer churrasco na
rua provavelmente uma grande cidade
temos grandes acessos a vias de
comunicação a grandes hospitais escolas
pois após nossos filhos mas cumpre ocupa
e pensará que deve estar mais distante
idéia
nós pedimos ao encostar-se globa
emprestado não os alunos podem estar por
casar
pelo menos é o que diz a minha avó só
pelos saltos precisa pois não se pode
envolver voltando a voltando a conversa
com minha amiga estava a dizer que o
movimento é é possível fazer com as
todas as atividades na na rua
claro que a curto prazo é curto prazo
não passa pela cabeça de nós é assistir
uma cirurgia muito bem planeada e super
ligada no meio da rua mas isto é cor
praça mas no exemplo da minha vida na
minha amiga costura educação básica
surge logo a ideia de que não dá
explicações no no meio da rua
o argumento que as crianças vão montar
com atenção com ser influenciadas pelos
temas externos não é valeu eu vi que
elas consigam estar menos até do que já
estão na sala de aula
por isso é possível a outra coisa já
vimos que é possível fazer churrascos já
vimos que é possível fazer linhas
concertos já que é possível fazer um
número um sem número de coisas na rua o
passo a seguir é mais difícil combatê
pelo menos em portugal é vergonha eo meu
quando isso é só pensarmos em criar o
primeiro jardim também tivemos de sair
até porque nós nós somos de água é uma
cidade pequena
então a gente acaba por conhecer por
saber que somos quem são os nossos pais
quem é que quer que os nossos irmãos
então estratégia que nós tentámos
arranjar foi ocupamos a nossa retina
fizemos este primeiro jardim no
anonimato durante a noite ea cidade
nasceu com o novo jardim foi foi claro
uma uma iniciativa já lá e pra nós foi
foi fantástico
depois deste despacho que conseguimos
combater a combater o medo ea vergonha
a outra coisa tem que estar preparados
com trabalhamos na rua que é crítica
tudo que fazemos na rua deve ser feito
de todos com todos e para todos tentando
respeitar o máximo possível é as pessoas
e mais uma vez tentamos arranjar uma
estratégia
nós gostamos muito está na rua e falar
com as pessoas e falar com os velhinhos
da vida às histórias histórias como o
sal churrasco está a fazê lo a conhecer
nossas e nós estamos a fazer em casa
vencer em casa o fumo
nós ficamos dessas histórias e tentamos
trazê lo a pagar e isso faz com que as
pessoas se identifiquem com nosso
trabalho como eram pelo menos preservar
a e respeitá lo
claro que é muito diferente quando
pensamos em fazer uma peça ela diz que o
museu onde o anda mesmo a partida não
será analisada está a partida só vai ver
quem quer ver na rua não
na rua quando faz uma peça esta pode
pode ser vista por toda a gente por quem
goste porque não gosta e também pode
eu não diria ser vandalizada mas podem
sofrer a e eu até acho que é desejável e
acho que é que é muito bom que se
interajam com elas não gostam gostam de
uma planta do nosso jardim e trocam por
outra vez que respeite o princípio como
foi feito o intervenção pra mim parece
me parece muito bem
cada vez mais os movimentos como como
como que nós criamos o movimento
organizá lo cada vez mais a participação
pública vem vai nu vencendo vai fazer
parte do discurso mas só nos últimos
anos é que tenha existido alguma alguma
prática quase sempre com resultados
muito interessantes e primeiramente
mudam atirados exemplo disso temos os
vários projectos apresentados os
orçamentos participativos nos diferentes
municípios
e aqui agora temos também projetos
interessantíssimos como como o bairro de
vaz irado mais rentáveis upe até o telex
haver aqui uma questão que eu acho que é
pertinente a pensar se todos nós todos
estes grupos que tentam fazer alguma
coisa na rua em frente que fazem da rua
no fundo é a sua casa todos andamos a
trabalhar muito bem e dar o setor
público e pode começar a responsabilizar
a shannon é obrigação de os fazer este
tipo de intervenções e melhorias na
cidade e passam em bercy responsáveis e
responsáveis e é preciso estarmos muito
atentos a esses para todos nós e
principalmente do setor público em
tentar arranjar mecanismos de conseguir
financiar conseguir promover ainda mais
importante a longo prazo conseguir criar
uma visão de futuro como é que este
projeto todos podem unir para que não
parecem desconectados e desligados mas
se uma coisa sólida e forte e do futuro
e nem toda a gente ou o tenha muito
tempo mesmo tem mesmo contava nem ter a
mesma vontade de participar na vida na
vida da silva e há sempre as pessoas
consumiram papel liderança ea outras
pessoas que vão assumir o papel de
seguidores papéis de colaboradores
outro rapaz tão importante como como
como a liderança mas uma coisa é certa é
é a rua dá muito bom espaço para todos
nós sabemos por nossa liberdade e nossa
criatividade em prática um espaço
gigante é ver livre para todos nós e por
muito por muito esforço cidades que
existam complemento fantástico
literatura também ela também era
deslumbrante
o predador elementos de fera e o que os
torna diferentes uma das outras
é o capital humano ea vontade das
pessoas que nela vivem
sem isso elas seriam meros blocos sem
barulho sem alma
olhem mais pavor nem que seja pela
janela do posto corpos
obrigado
[Aplausos]